so the sec has just confirmed that elon
musk has taken a huge position in
bitcoin so his company invests
1.5 billion dollars into bitcoin now
this is pretty insane because
what it does is it gives bitcoin
credibility and it cements bitcoin as
that store of value
there's a lot of people out there who
still believe bitcoin is a scam think
it's a ponzi scheme
but the fourth most recognized company
in the world tesla
taking such a position in something so
new
really solidifies bitcoin as that store
of value and it gives it legitimacy this
is incredible now tesla are also talking
about
taking bitcoin as payments so very soon
people that want to buy
tesla products that want to buy tesla
cars can actually use
bitcoin to do so so this is going to be
incredible for bitcoin's price action so
i for one i'm very excited
not just to see where the price of
bitcoin goes but which companies follow
suit